You'd be forgiven for forgetting about
Passengers, but Jennifer Lawrence never will.
If you can't recall, Passengers is a sci-fi movie
focusing on Lawrence and Chris Pratt's characters,
Aurora Lane and Jim Preston. They are two
passengers among many on an interstellar journey,
and Aurora and Jim wake up early - 90
years too early, as a matter of fact,
with no obvious way to go back to sleep.
When you have 90 years to kill with someone,
things are likely to turn romantic out of
sheer boredom, if nothing else. However,
even though Lawrence and Pratt
have strong on-screen chemistry,
the act of filming those steamy scenes was
decidedly flaccid, especially for Lawrence.
The actress recently opened up about
the many ways in which her experience
getting intimate with her co-star
was less than ideal — through no
real fault of Pratt's. That doesn't mean
she despised filming Passengers. Instead,
whenever she had to get all lovey-dovey in
the film, things turned awkward quickly.
During a roundtable discussion
hosted by The Hollywood Reporter,
Jennifer Lawrence revealed
that Passengers had her first
intimate scene ever on film and she used
liquid courage to help her get through.
Lawrence said she felt extremely awkward
knowing the scenes she had to film. So,
to prepare for her big moment, she drank. A lot.
All that alcohol had unintended consequences,
though. Lawrence grappled with extreme anxiety
in between shoots. While Lawrence knew her job
was to kiss the then-married-to-Anna Faris
Chris Pratt, even the feigned infidelity
gave her a queasy feeling every time the two
had to lock lips in front of the cameras.
To make matters worse, the actual process of
filming romantic scenes was less than fun.
One scene that was cut from the film required
Pratt and Lawrence to rock a table back and forth,
and neither of them liked it. When
asked about the scene, Lawrence said:
"Sex scenes are the most
unsexy things in the world."
"I can't think of anything else to try to save us,
and I don't even want to think about it anymore."
The duo's onscreen romance also led to some real
world problems. When acting in a romantic movie,
there is always the unspoken fear that
fiction will bleed over into reality,
complicating real-life relationships. When
two stars have blazing on-screen chemistry,
it's a law of the universe that the rumor mill
is going to kick into overdrive. Just ask Bradley
Cooper and Lady Gaga. While many celebrities
understand that this is part of the job and can
find the mental fortitude to rise above it, this
gossip almost always takes a psychological toll.
Tales of behind-the-scenes infidelity spread
like wildfire after Chris Pratt and his wife,
actress Anna Faris, announced their divorce.
Jennifer Lawrence was at the top of the list
of potential causes, due unfairly to the romantic
scenes she filmed with Pratt during Passengers.
Lawrence shot those rumors down during an
interview with InStyle, stating that the
film had already been wrapped for years by the
time Faris and Pratt announced their divorce.
Not even Anna Faris bought into the
rumors. In her memoir Unqualified,
Faris states that she was good friends with
Jennifer Lawrence and was embarrassed by the
gossip. Faris also writes that Lawrence
was apologetic about the whole thing,
as she knew it was adding even more
stress onto Faris during a stressful time.
While Jennifer Lawrence has mostly unpleasant
memories of filming Passengers' romance scenes,
it wasn't all bad. In true Jennifer
Lawrence-style, she liked them the
most when they went off the rails, generating
some of the best moments on the film's set.
During an interview with Lawrence, USA Today
discovered that one of Passengers' funniest
moments was completely unintentional. In the
movie, Lawrence and Pratt's characters eventually
don space suits, and after they take the helmets
off, they go in for a kiss... but bump into each
other because the suits are so big. That wasn't
supposed to happen. They were supposed to lock
lips passionately, but the unforeseen bulky
nature of the space suits transformed the scene
into a comedic bit. Everyone on set liked it so
much that it was left in the film's final cut.
This unscripted moment is yet another entry in the
list of movie bloopers that were deemed superior
to the intended versions. Coincidentally, another
recent example of such a scene also involves Chris
Pratt — that time he accidentally dropped an
Infinity Stone in Guardians of the Galaxy. Oops.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.